diese yuki frage was ist deine lieblings
stellung dazu sage ich nur sehr herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video zu einem
unbeschreiblich guten kiju denn wir sind
hier auf einer couch das ist keine
gewöhnliche diese couch hat sogar zwei
rote decken das heißt dass steht dafür
dass wir heute ein extrem tuning machen
ja nachholen nicht so diese billigen
fragen wann wurdest du geboren sondern
wir klotzen heute mal richtig rein ja
few days an sich gab schon tausendmal
deswegen müssen wir auf jeden fall als
youtuber heutzutage und es machen die
ordentlichen sind deswegen brauchen wir
einfach so richtig bretter als fragen ja
ich habe natürlich gefragt stellt mir
peinlich oder extremer fragen vielleicht
kommt ihr ins video und sie haben jetzt
schon nach 43 minuten schöne 500
antworten
ich habe auch eine stunde tweet
abgesetzt hey ich bin einfach 300 v ich
werde heute einfach alle antworten auf
ehrliche aus einer auf auch auf krank
auch auf extrem er so viel wie die
fläche von lena wie oft hast du schon
ovid geraucht und leute wie gesagt juni
auf ehrlich deswegen schon ein paar mal
hat der stelle sollte ich auch noch
sagen dass das heute kein cubase indem
ich ein gutes vorbild bin also wenn ihr
euren eltern irgendwie zeigen wollte
zeigt ihnen nicht dieses video ich würde
sagen schon zweistellig aber auch gar
keinen fall dreistellig also zwischen 10
und 100 x 100 x geld und diese nach dem
junkie das oder extras sowie fall nicht
katja hat ebay fragt wann das wäre das
letzte mal einen porno angeschaut
katja in stunden oder in minuten leute
das geht richtig ab heute ist wirklich
wirklich girlie alter noemi ascot fragen
standest du schon mal auf eine leere
beziehungsweise fanden
wie attraktiv
ich hatte eigentlich immer ziemlich
hässliche lehrerin ich hatte tatsächlich
es ist eigentlich mega ungefähr da
irgendwie der schulbehörde oder sofort
klar da hatte ich schon von fällen
gehört wo schüler geklagt haben wir die
lehrer einfach nicht heiß war und man
hatte keine fantasien über so der lehrer
so geht es mir nämlich ich bin richtig
richtig geschädigte leute dieses kind er
heute wird richtig schönen helena ldm
fragt meist das logo hast du schon mal
einen jungen geküsst nein ich bin ich
sehr liberal eingestellt also ich bin
sehr offen aber dass er im juni hat
arena henry l s gefragt hast du schon
mal bei einem date kino oder essen ein
ständer bekommen wahrscheinlich schon
katharina hat fragt auch noch mal wie
war dein erster kurs mit oder ohne wie
alt warst du wo fand dieser kurs statt
leute ich hätte damals so richtig
richtig schiss davor zum ersten mal
medien zu küssen war ich da wo ich
glaube so zwölf oder dreizehn es war
somit der erste so pseudo freunde wo man
so tut als sei etwas zu sagen weil alle
so tun als wären sie zusammen und ich
mag es waren damals auch viel unterwegs
und da war so zwei freunde mit der einen
weich zu sein
max war mit der anderen nicht zusammen
aber wir dann immer zu viert unterwegs
da war mir ein busbahnhof die zwei
mädels und max und ich und dann ging es
darum sich zu verabschieden dann dachte
ich boah ey hast du jetzt schon so lange
hinausgezögert du musst jetzt einfach
mal loslegen und die andere seite sind
willst du mich hoch wie an
aber dann hat die andere seite die hoch
zeit gewonnen dann bin ich bei der
verabschiedung also einfach auf sie zu
aber so hin und weg und viel werden sie
auch so auch okay das ist jetzt passiert
ist aber ich gehe jetzt auch mal guten
ein witz oder ohne ohne hanna equity lp
wie fragt wurdest du schon mal beim sex
erwischt und das ist tatsächlich eine
sache die mir gott sei dank nicht
passiert ist aber man hört auch schon
diverse geschichten von freunden die
alle so erzählen was da so alles
passieren kann zum beispiel allein vom
eigenen hund erwischt zu werden leute
mal angenommen die seiten wäre wenn
solche gerade mit eurem freund zugang ja
und das hört ein hund selbstverständlich
und er holt denkt sich im moment war
mein herrchen komische geräusche von
sich gäbe bestimmt gerade angegriffen
die muss sich verteidigen und dann rennt
deines zimmer rein und versucht im
zweifelsfall einfach euren typen dann
von euch runter zu bekommen oder
wegzubekommen
japan stellt eine sehr praktische frage
und zwar was machen jungs mit ihrem
penis wenn sie sich eine unterhose
anziehen das ist tatsächlich ein
sachverhalt über den ich meinem leben
noch nicht so sehr nachgedacht habe ist
eine frage die boxershorts anzieht ob
das bequem ist oder nicht ja wenn es
sich bequem ist dann sortiert man eben
seine schlechte teile auf einer seite
oder die andere meistens links lena g
fragt schon mal ein richtig üblen korb
von einem mädchen bekommen wenn ja wann
und wie das wort tatsächlich das erste
medien dass ich verliebt war das war so
eine richtige securities damals icq
kennt paar von euch vielleicht noch und
ich war so blöde verliebten dieses mädel
julia hier ist die damals ich war so
dumm verliebt in jesus unfassbaren dann
die ganze nation er geschrieben pipapo
hier ist aber ich denke schon dass ich
mir auch scheisse scheisse degas
verkackt nicht da habe ich überall
gefragt ob er ins kino gehen ins kino
gegangen
direkt nach dem kino weit ich überhaupt
kein plan hatte habe ich sie gefragt ob
sie hingehen bild für sie war das
offensichtlich zu früh oder sie hatte
gar kein bock und dementsprechend es
kanye hält neid hat den fall gibt es
irgendwelche fetische bei dir
schau doch selbst ist der einzige tipp
dir hier ist dies keine fehler auf
oder ist dieser tisch für eine fee
entworfen ich glaube dass nicht alte und
wir haben keine fetisch die sorge hätte
mir die fahrt bist du noch jungfrau hoch
und tg jannis töpfer antwortet nee ist
ein stecker herzchen tatsächlich nein
programm ersten mal war das ein
riesenthema für mich das ist eine sache
über die man reden kann da eigentlich
beschäftigt dass alle aber niemand redet
mir ist so viel stress gemacht
unfassbar aber es ist eigentlich mehr
gültig das einzige was hast du schon mal
steckte des 56 das einzige was hast du
schon mal sex gehabt von hast du schon
mal eine wassermelone auf die autobahn
geworfen unterscheidet ist dass sich auf
die eine art und weise eine rasse erhält
man auf die anderen dich leute widmen
dem thema schon krass viel
aufmerksamkeit machte sich damit viel zu
viel stress und die sache ist wirklich
leute wenn ihr euch selbst zu viel
stress macht dann haut nicht hin
überhaupt mir zwei letzte fragen auf die
haben wir schnell durch von sturm die
sie hast du dein bruder von anfang an
seiner geburt gemacht ich kann mich
nicht wirklich dran aber ich muss ich
richtig gehasst haben ich statt damals
an maxis kinderbett und das erste was
ich gesagt habe ich sehe meinen kleinen
bruder zum ersten
ich komme also ein kinderbett und ich
sagte ihm erst mal so was richtig
gemacht ich habe in dem moment gewalt
angedroht das war das erste was ich
meinen kleinen bruder gesagt habe als
auf die welt kam und zum abschluss kiri
galt diese yuki fragt was ist deine
lieblings stellung dazu sage ich nur das
was man sie im krieg hat mir einige echt
gute frage gestellt danke bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss und natürlich wie
immer